this is one of my favorite scenes from
the movie Spirited Away the main
character Chihiro who's just 10 years
old has just gone through some really
crazy stuff her parents got turned into
pigs and she's really had to fight her
way to survive in this very strange
World by herself and now she has to go
find this witch to ask if she could save
his friend
Haku and for almost 2 minutes nothing
really happens it's just chiro sitting
on the train but it's potentially one of
the most powerful moments in the movie
cuz it gives us space to breathe and
reflect on what this character just went
through Studio gibl movies are full of
scenes like this empty moments where we
can process what's going on and build
empathy and a connection to the
characters and the story on a deeper
level